he made me shoot him  kept saying I wasn't real it was almost  as if you're a different person you're  right he sometimes can become into  firmers your wig what am I doing here  you don't remember dark army turned on  us  I think I'm next stage two has never  called off society architect plenty of  work to do I can stop this no you pull  the ripcord now they will have won World  catastrophes like this they occur  because I'm like allowed something is  happening it could be big this is going  to mark the end of a Corp this is your  moment you cannot turn away now if you  pull the right strings a puppet will  dance any way you desire the dark army  needs to know what he's done you  understand the consequences she's a  terrorist  if you don't do anything they'll be no  coming back from this  you